bien dormi
où est mon téléphone c'est parti
tu peux m'aider à le chercher
allô bonjour
[Musique]
excuse-moi mais je dois vérifier mon
gadget au plus vite
on doit aller se mettre au vers ce
weekend dis-moi juste oui dites-le oui
c'est une escapade coquine je suis
absolument pas d'accord
alors c'est vraiment perdu c'est ça qui
est magique dans cet endroit vous êtes
venu jusqu'ici pour pouvoir vous
retrouver
[Musique]
juste devant le restaurant très bien
elle est canon vous devez avoir un sacré
engin pour avoir chopé avec votre tête
d'abruti
quoi
c'est assez qui elle c'est Lulu salut
Lulu elle parle pas ça laveur
c'est à une cup Predator très dangereux
laisse-moi tranquille vous aurez besoin
de ça oui c'est clair on a pas besoin de
se fuser on a notre permis pourquoi vous
êtes pas plus angoissé que ça il y a pas
d'électricité il y a pas de wifi
pied gauche attends chérie
[Rires]
je fais des provisions
je sais pas pourquoi je trouve ça drôle
on va y arriver
vous étiez pas en train de prendre de la
coque tous les deux
[Musique]